i'm gonna start with this because it's a
frustrating thing for me um so i'm
curious uh how can a film win six
academy awards get nominated for ten but
the director not get nominated it's the
most asinine bizarre i mean that's why
snubs are such a thing and that's why we
all talk about them but that's a snub of
a snub of a snub
that i just thought was an impossibility
but given you know everything about the
academy awards there are many
impossibilities that actually
materialized so
it's all part of the game right now i
don't know is it post pandemic mentality
is it whatever whatever it is i don't
understand it he helmed the whole thing
it's his creation it's his
interpretation
and i love how he dealt with it then
i'll shut up but how he dealt with it
was all he did was go right into praise
for the 10 people who were nominated and
good for him i don't have to do that on
the other hand
dude neither do i i think first of all
dune is my favorite film of last year
by a mile denise a genius everything he
did with that movie is
amazing um
and you know so obviously if you've
never seen dune for the love of god push
play on it it's phenomenal you know it's
a it's a and we can't wait to get into
the next one which comes in july which
will be fun
which which leads me to my next thing
which is um for
i mean i know you're a part of dune too
but can you
confirm for people that you are a part
of doom 2 i am a part of doom 2 to the
to the ridiculous extent of when
somebody mentioned to me that wasn't on
imdb i actually went out of my way to
call liz and say can you please put that
on mdb because it's a proud moment for
me man i'm i'm and by the way javier and
i had a similar thing that we both
admitted to each other at the oscars
because we both have a little bit of a
punch right now
and and we had talked to didn't he we
hadn't read anything we talked to me the
week before and he was like you know you
guys are like fighting the whole time
and you've been in the desert with the
fremen and all that and we [ __ ]
panicked
like look down and saw this little
friend that we've been holding on our
abdomen and i was like i'm [ __ ] like
so we were both on like full diet mode
at the oscars even though you absolutely
couldn't tell we were on we were already
in diet mode in panic diet mode
that's funny but it will pay off when
you are filming in july it will
absolutely you know
um if if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
these are good questions dude um
why
what how many films do i have that i can
say three
i'll give you two or three two or three
i would say
flirting with disaster
i would say no country
and i would say
god what after that
no country i don't know what after that
but uh uh and why why what what i would
intend to do is create
enough diversity that they felt like i
had a a talent to play um different
characters
um what is the most you've ever prepared
for a role like we're talking i'll stay
with that w i i i got so stressed out i
got belle's palsy and we had to postpone
production for six weeks
okay that that's definitely prepping
that's that's commitment
which of the films you've been involved
with do you think changed the most in
the editing room
wow that's a good question jonah hex
which just only got worse
um
what else not no country at all i think
what was being put together along
uh while we were filming and i saw uh
daley's was pretty much exactly what i
saw
but even with more impact
what's another one um
probably avengers too
you know your intention and your
experiment while you're doing it and
then what they came up with was
surprising to me i thought very
effective but surprising
speaking of marvel um have you spoken to
feige about cable now that deadpool 3
has been
announced no
have you spoken to sean levy or
i haven't
and i know all those guys i haven't
spoken to ryan i know shawn really well
obviously i know kevin well
and i i uh no i haven't heard word one
so i do not know
moving into why
moving into why i get to talk to you so
uh i purposely only watched the first
two episodes so i wouldn't feel inclined
to like just pepper you with spoiler
questions yeah first two episodes are
fantastic and each one ends on what
could be a series finale um it was that
designed on purpose or all the episodes
sort of like that where they end on a
holy [ __ ] moment
yeah you know what i don't know if it
was particularly designed that way but i
think like what you were talking about
before editorially it kind of ended up
that way where you have this connective
tissue of the characters but i do feel
that when i watch it and this is just my
personal opinion that they're very they
feel very one-acty do you know what i
mean they could stand by themselves as
their own story and i don't know if
that's a bad or a good thing i just
think it's what exists
um but yeah yeah i i think that was
partially intentional but became even
more so during the editorial process
um how have you actually been describing
the series to friends and family
um a hybrid of a western and
metaphysical elements that could stand
in the whole could stand in for anything
you want it to
whether it's you know uh the kind of
psychic block or chaotic block that we
have on going around right now uh
secrets
um america anything you want it to stand
in for when people are confronted with
something that they don't have control
over the layers that get peeled away of
survival mechanisms that you've created
in your life and are left with a very
raw bleeding um
stealth that's revealed
i don't say it like that but it's
something like that
sure oh this is the kind of show though
that i think as people watch they're
going to want to know
do they have the answers figured out do
they know ultimately where this is all
going so i'll ask you do you guys know
ultimately where you would like this to
end like do you have that sort of arc
and figured out or is it sort of like
we're going to do it season by season
you know what i mean i think what we've
dealt with is season by season at this
point i think we've talked about a final
ending you know and where this what
we're working toward
but i think the biggest thing is popping
from one season or season one to season
two because this is something that i
haven't done in 20 plus years
so it's an interesting medium for me to
be able to explore not just from a
character standpoint a lot of people say
that it's great to see a character go
through all this stuff but because of
the sucker punch of the metaphysical
elements of it there's so many different
directions you can take it
and and what i like about it personally
is it takes
like the typical
western genre hero and it turns it on
its ass because
it it it you know this like what i said
this construction of machismo
is is blown apart and uh and and it
affects all his secrets everything that
he deems his integrity
is is is backfired and it ends up
destroying the the core of what his you
know family foundation once was there is
uh some cool cinematography in the first
two episodes an unusual cinematography
and what it wasn't what i was expecting
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of the show that there's some pretty
cool shots
i think i was talking to somebody else
who's doing an apple show right now and
they had a lot of a lot of the same
issues came up and when
with this with i think this medium i
think the cinematography has a huge huge
role to play because how that tone and
how that look
is really dictates kind of how you feel
about what's going on and it just within
that different medium so
i see some cinematographers that were
better than other cinematographers and
the cinematographers that were great
you know why is the show better why does
the acting feel better why does it you
know what i'm saying
and i think the elements were such a
major part of this show that the
cinematography plays a major major part
in how you feel about watching it
in an ideal world how many seasons would
you like this show to last oh my god
dude i could get in trouble if i
answered that question i have i have the
number in my head
is is it more than three i just did
something i just did something so you'll
have to rewind this you can i will i
will rewind yeah no but the thing i what
i like about shows like this the high
concept shows is that you know it's
eight episodes sometimes they're six
sometimes they're ten and there's no
filler each episode is like really
contained and given to the audience
stuff and by the way season season it
can change season to season we could do
eight episodes this season and then do
six next season or do 10 next season it
all dictates itself which is very
different than the tv that i was used to
back in the day what were you going to
ask sorry well no i was also going to
say the running time of each episode
could be completely different
that thank god
yes that's what people don't realize
it's like why are we so strapped to
certain narrative structures
now that they're streaming and this kind
of stuff you can do anything there's no
right or wrong it's just what you're
used to and i do think that navigating
through this new medium people are
having
i mean it's it's it's a learning process
and i don't think we've learned it yet
and i think it's so new to us because
back when like you when you were talking
about network tv and all that you had to
you know it's like advertising has to go
here so this has to so an hour-long show
has to be exactly 48 minutes or whatever
that was and now you're not dictated in
that way anymore dictated to in that way
anymore which is great because there's
no it also is more pressure because
there's no reason for it to be
bad other than a bad version of
storytelling
and and and if that's what we've done
then i will take it like
for lack of a better word men but um
if it's not then
all the work and all the elements that
we dealt with which were very very
difficult um was worth it
how close did you come to doing a
different tv show over the last two
decades or was this the first thing that
really got you interested no there was
one show i won't say what it is because
i know who's doing it um and he's going
to be great but there was one show i was
interested in it was the subject matter
that that that i i thought was
unsustaining for me personally i was
like i don't know if i want to talk
about this if this goes more than one
season i don't know if i want to talk
about this for years to come
this thing is sustaining to me because i
brought brought back a lot of things for
me and brought back reading ray bradbury
and isaac asimov when i was a kid and
that was totally inspiring kind of broke
open my whole world
outside of ranch life
and then
you know it was my good friend sam as
you know sam shepard and after sam
passed you know a lot of times i would
do this anyway even when he was alive
i'd go back to his early stuff and there
was a great kind of
marriage between the supernatural and
and the western genre
and i always found that really
fascinating so it you know i hearken
back to that because that was always
inspiring to me and i loved exploring
the idea of exploring that so there were
personal reasons too man
that i have to look at and say because i
know me if i have disinterest that's
just not a good thing it's not a good
thing for me it's not a good thing for
anybody
and and and i make sure that that's the
case with every job i do but it was
particularly with this because we know
i have no control of how long it will
last i mean if this went
season after season after season after
season like what about it well we're out
on a ten thousand acre ranch in santa fe
new mexico that i could think of worse
things to do uh
yes um for people that watched the first
two episodes what would you actually
what do you want to tease about the
series for like what's to come or is it
one of these things where you would
rather sort of people you know what i
mean like how much do you want people to
know
you know what i think i think i'll say
this and i wouldn't say this if i didn't
believe it which i think you know about
me is a lot of series you'll see the
first two and the first two are great
and then you continue to watch it and it
kind of slips off a little bit what i
believe about this series is it
continually gets better
and to me seven and eight are great
they're like if i can say there's two
episodes that are the best episodes in
the show at seven and eight um i think
the show progressively gets better and
more interesting and finds itself more
um
as as as a tone that we that was being
dictated to us
that we that we that we finally adhered
to
but um you know and then once you go
into a second season if you do go into a
second season then you're in a different
place you're like okay we know what this
is now but i truly think that this was
an experiment that was a really fun
playground of behavior
that people will find dynamic regardless
that's my last question even though i
think that prime's supposed to wrap
already but what you just touched on it
a little bit one of the things that i've
spoken to so many show runners and
actors and directors is that the first
season of any show you're figuring out
the infrastructure who the characters
really are how to make it how many d
like what it really takes to make the
series what did you learn
making this season that you will
absolutely take with you to season two
to make season two even better
i i honestly man i think that it you
know in in and
there are moments the difference between
making this series and making movies in
the last making most movies in the last
15 years is what i've learned
in making those movies is people who are
really good at what they do strangely
have a lack of pretense
and and and they're more interested in
the storytelling and the skill and the
manifesting of the story and the way
that they see it and and so if there's
any kind of verve or anger or
frustration that goes into it it's going
into the right places
trying to get the right result
and whatever that means and i and i
think that
in this in this medium there's a lot
there we don't like i say we don't know
if we should use filmmakers or if we
should use skilled tv people from the
networks or that like where
who has the best version of how to do
this
medium and i think that there was some
of that during this shoot where
people who weren't necessarily right for
that you know uh
that category of filmmaking um
that that was a learning process and
that was kind of a shuffling that would
go on and that was as a producer that
was a very difficult thing to do
and then just keeping up morale because
of the
of the elements of being you know
working nights in eight degree weather
and then working in 106 degree weather
three months later during the day
so i'm more used to that i think most
people
and uh and did you say something
no i was listening to you no no um that
i i'm more used to that than most people
but i think that keeping up morale was
was an important element throughout this
because it was a hard shoot it was a
hard shoot
everybody knows it was a hard shoot
yeah i can only imagine on that note i
gotta go i'm just gonna say i'm looking
forward to seeing this and a certain
future moving
right on all right let me see let's see
worn on purpose that's great that's
awesome a little sand worm
i see it
anyway listen man i wish you nothing but
the best and you know thank you so much
for your time
see you soon